hello everyone and welcome to the last
game we'll be showing from the ftx
crypto cup round six it is uh a round
before the final round and uh the final
round will be extremely action-packed as
we will have a really really incredible
uh match up but before we get to that we
first have to check out what happened in
the game uh between magnus carlson and
alvireza firuja and this is a game from
the blitz section uh so let me just fix
that
later on the bird just give me a few
seconds there we go
all right nicely done i want to trick
you guys uh so as you've seen uh the
match started by magnus losing the first
game of the rapids then magnus
immediately bounced back he won game two
then game three and game four of the
rapids ended in a draw and this is now
the blitz section uh one of the blitz
sections ended in a draw and this one uh
might not have so let's dive straight
into it magnus has the white pieces and
he opens with c4 yeah sorry about that
uh so c4 he goes for the english opening
uh same way as he did in game two of the
rap it's the one that he won but in that
game although it is accounted with
knight to f6 he here he goes e5
we have g3 by magnus preparing to think
of his light square bishop knight to f6
with bishop to g to end bishop to c5
we have d3 and now alireza castle so a
very very open way of
tackling the english and as you can see
magnus put his pawns on light squares
his light square bishop is on this
diagonal so you don't have to worry
about the developing it and the dark
square bishop free to roam in between
the pawns on light squares we have
knight to f3 d6 and now knight to c3 and
here uh there is a game from 2019
between uh liam roy and the jordan palm
forest
where a6 was played but here we have c6
by le reza and it is now as of move six
that we have a completely new game so
magnus castles and now comes pawn to a5
we have pawn to d4 sort of a delayed d4s
first magnus played d3 and d4 and you
might be expecting some further
development of the pieces but uh if you
play something like bishop to g5 then
all it is immediately plays h6 and what
is the bishop really doing there yeah i
mean you don't really have a good square
to go back do you don't want to give it
up for the knight so that's why it makes
sense to sort of waste the tempo now on
un pawn to d4 e capture sunday for
knight captures on d4 and now pawn to a4
alireza says you will not be playing any
uh b4 ideas anytime soon pawn to e3 and
now pawn all the way to a3 and now while
magnus could play b3 he decides that the
queen to c2 is better it's a developing
move and if pawn ever captures on b2 he
will uh develop his bishop to this
diagonal so rook 38 by le reza knights
to b3 now attacking the bishop and here
a characters on b2 we have bishop
captures that's not a bishop captures
bishop captures and here alireza played
a most peculiar move he played bishop to
e6
and the magnus is ready to capture on c5
and the mesopal it is a spawn structure
now uh bishop to a3 here that prevents
knight captures on c5 and also puts
well this bishop uh on a nice a3 square
offering a trade of dark square bishop
so that's one way to do it but after all
it is bishop to e6 magnus just
captures on c5 so he destroys the
respawn structure d captures on c5 and
not knight back to e2 preparing knight
to afford to now put uh pressure on this
slide square bishop so knight bd7 we
have knight to f4 and now queen to e7 we
have pawn to a4 by magnus um trying to
get pawn all the way to a5 then bishop
comes to c3 and the pawn will be
cemented here already plays rook to a6
he wants to go after the pawn before
this happens uh but magnus says there's
no way for you to stop this rook after
b1 we have rook eat the a8 and now just
bishop to c3 magnus uh plays this even
though the c for pawn now seems
vulnerable uh but if you can't run c4
just bishop captures an f6 and that's it
the queen is attacked the bishop is
attacked
alireza can just resign here so after
bishop to c3 rook 6 back to a7 and now
pawn to a5 now the pawn is nicely
cemented here so you don't have to worry
about any b5 ideas from black
we have knight to e8 remaneuvering the
knight now now the knight can come to c7
then maybe to a6 to b4 uh we have queen
to d3 preparing to bring the rook over
to the d-file and put pressure on on
black's d file
knight to d to f6 and now we have
finally knight captures on e6 we have
queen captures and the rook to d1
so the rook no longer needed on the b
file as alireza put his rook here to
defend the b7 pawn but now if uh all it
is a plays a weird move let's say moves
the knight then queen to d7 is
definitely the way to go so knight to c7
by alireza remaneuvering the knight over
to b4 to put pressure on magnus's queen
and now magnus plays e4 all combined
with the plan of bringing the queen to
d7 he wants to play e5 kick away the
knight and then play queen to d7 we have
knight to a6 pawn to e5 and now knight
to e8 and now pawn to f4 cementing his
pawn on e5 but also preparing pawn to f5
and here there's uh
there's very little you can do about
this you could try the media the g6 but
um
magnus's position is just a whole lot
better so here knight to b4 is what all
it is that tries
attacks the queen and now if magnus
moves the queen then g6 and the position
might be uh you know playable for black
even though it will be better for white
uh however here magnus goes for f5 right
away and you can't trade queens if all
it is that trades queens here then your
knight is hanging f6 is hanging this is
uh game over for example knight b4
captures on f7 king captures and now the
rook infiltrates via the d7 square and
now the bishop player will become
unstoppable for example king here now
you can play bishop here bishop here or
you can push the pawn to e6 or
open up an attack on the pawn right away
push e7 maybe then bring the bishop here
so many many options
uh so after this f5 move we have queen
to e7 by alga and now just queen to d7
magnus really playing this like like a
textbook game queen to g5 now trying to
go for some queen to e3 check maybe put
pressure on the bishop but magnus says
that is not happening pawn to e6 we have
captures captures and now just queen the
a3 check and king to h1 magnus says you
can never capture the bishop if you do
queen f7 checking hit and this will be
checkmate so after king to h1 already
played b6 he attacked uh magnus's queen
on d7 but here magnus just goes for the
spectacular a captures on b6 he attacks
the rook and he offers a full queen here
but if already accepts the queen it is a
forced uh winning sequence for magnus
which is quite quite impressive so i
will show it uh if rook captures on d7
then just e captures on d7 now the
knight is hanging and also the rook is
hanging so how can you defend this let's
say rook to d8 you are very happy to
give up a knight now come to rook to e1
attacking the queen and if of course the
queen moves then rook capture 78 check
ends the game so queen captures on e1
you will have to give back the queen
rook captures and it seems like you've
uh
sort of
gotten back into the game after knight
to d6 but here comes bishop capture
spawn captures and c5 now just removing
the defender of the e8 square and now
you really don't have a good move if the
knight moves just check wins the rook
and if of course you uh something real
captures on d7
then even bishop captures on c6 there's
no move here rook to d8 c captures on d6
and
still no moves for example rook captures
b7 you can even give up the bishop for
queening and if rook to d8 is just a
very nice rookie check you trade here
and then you promoted the pawn to a
queen on the next move so rook
characters and d7 is impossible for
alireza
uh so a characters and v6 must have felt
incredibly good uh when magnus played it
and now alireza plays knight to d3 it's
such a tricky move it's it's uh uh
really uh
maybe not the final resource but uh you
know he he definitely gives magnus an
opportunity to blunder for those of you
who are maybe new to chess maybe you
don't see immediately what he's going
for but if magnus plays something like
rook captures on a7 alireza has a
beautiful smothered mate here knight you
have to check and now of course you all
know what is happening king g1 only move
knight to h3 a double check from the
knight and the queen now if king here
this is checkmate so king the h1 and now
a wonderful queen sacrifice queen g1
check only move rook captures on g1 and
knight to f2 a beautiful smothered mate
so this is what alireza tries with this
tricky knight to d3 move uh but of
course magnus instantly spots this as uh
well it's very rare that someone will
overlook a smothered mate so just queen
captures on d3 now he grabs more
material queen captures and now uh it
would be very silly to capture the queen
if you capture the queen the nalida
easily wins the rook captures bishop
captures rook captures and now you have
to give up the bishop as well as there's
no way to get out of check so bishop f1
rook captures and now
alireza would simply be up a a full
piece and completely winning if rook
here
king he rook to b1 stops the past pawn
that's uh all there is to it so after
this queen captures and the three b
captures um on a7 magnus grabs the a7
rook
queen captures on c3 alireza grabs the
bishop and now bishop captures on c6
attacks the knight and the rook so you
have to move the rook
but there's really not a good square
because then a8 comes so here just uh
rook captures on a7 rook captures and
now queen captures on c4 so while
theresa has a queen and the knight
against the magnus's two rooks and the
bishop
but also there is the problem of the
past pawn on e6 and magnus just plays
rook to a8 point being that now if queen
captures uh then magnus uh just picks up
the queen rook captures an e8 check and
alireza has to part with the queen so
here g6 uh creating some breeding room
for his king now rook capture 78 with
check king g7 and now pawn to e7
so uh as you can see with the light
square bishop controlling this diagonal
and with the uh rook controlling the
back rank
there's no actual way of the queen ever
delivering check to the white king so
the only way is to deliver it through
the back rank or through this diagonal
as magnus controls this uh the queen is
helpless against
the white king so queen to e2 eliza goes
after the rook now comes rook to g8 to
check magnus just go for the uh easiest
way to win this he gives up the rook and
then if king captures pawn to e8 queen
will uh force the the trait here we can
even show it uh queen here or a rook
doesn't really matter captures counters
and magnus is up too much material so
after this check uh alireza plays queen
king to h6 still hoping to grab the rook
here uh but magnus even allows it just
e8 queen he gives up the rook on d1
queen captures king to g2 and now queen
to c2 with check now it is all over of
course the battalion will try to force
some sort of a perpetual king to f3 now
queen to f5 would check and kink the e3
magnus has to bring the king to an open
board
to stop the check at some point using
the bishop or the queen so queen g5
check king to e2 now comes queen to g
for check and bishop to f3 queen to c
for check we have king to f2 and now
queen to a to check the last trick
alireza has up his sleeve if queen to e2
then he can pick up the rook on g8 and
he would still be winning for magnus but
it would be annoying so magnus just
played bishop to e2 and he was in this
position animal 48 that alireza first
resigned the game and magnus wins the
match in the blitz section so he didn't
win it in rapid he didn't grab the full
points but he still won it in the in the
blitz section
uh
uh so here you resign because let's say
you play something c4 you want to push
your pass pawn it's a very simple
checkmate let's say queen e3 check the
king can't go back you have to go
you can't even go anywhere you have to
play g5 and then just queen captures
will be checkmate so
that's all there is to it so after
bishop to e2 of course all it is are
resigned and what does this mean for the
final round who can win the event uh
well these are the standings uh after uh
the the penultimate round the magnus is
leading with 15 points uh followed by uh
pragnanda with 13 points pragananda had
a brutal brutal game again a match
against young sister of duda where he
lost uh but he was on his way to bounce
back in the blitz section and then uh
prague just overlooked the mate in one
it was brutal it was uh i mean i've seen
a video when prague did it you know his
headphones just flew all the way back he
his chair flew all the way back he
couldn't believe what he had done uh but
still as he made it past the rapids he
he went into the blitz tie breaks uh he
got one point so he has he is on 13
points and in the final round we have
the clash between pragmata and the
magnus carlsen which means uh only the
two of them can win uh the ftx crypto
cup alireza isn't 12 points uh but um
there's no way actual way for him to win
even if he wins and he's playing against
lavon arunian even if he beats levon
and if he beats him in the rapids he
will get the full three points he will
have 15 exactly as magnus but if magnus
remains on 15 that will mean that he
lost to alireza in the rapid section
which means uh sorry to the pregnant in
the
rapid section which means that prague
will be on 16 points as he will be
awarded three points so even if alireza
wins and magnus loses in the rapids we
will have pragnanda on 16 and magnus and
alireza will be sharing second place
with um with 15 points so basically only
magnus and prag can win this and they
face each other in the final round
that's incredible it is absolutely i
mean wild it is more than we could have
asked for and it will be a great day for
chess
uh so that's the game and a little bit
of info about the standings hope you
guys enjoyed that uh i would like to
thank attila
uh brian
and akshay pandit for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the ftx
crypto cup until it finishes and then we
are showing the game between stockfish
and chess master grandmaster edition
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day